beards are still undeniably cool but
they're not for everybody so today we're
going to look at some of our favorite
celebrities and decide whether or not a
beard is the right look for them my name
is Matty Conrad and this is the grooming
[Music]
guide Ryan
Reynolds now first of all speaking as a
Canadian I just want to make it clear to
you that Ryan Reynolds is a godamn
National Treasure now we're used to
seeing Ryan Reynolds quite often either
with a beard or without one so this is
kind of a tough call here's a picture of
Ryan Reynolds with a beard that is nice
and short and not outlined and it gives
him a really nice friendly Vibe
generally handsome he's got a bit of a
Rough and Ready look but let's have a
look at his beard when it is overg
groomed there is an element to
overgrooming your beard that can start
to make you look like a mid90s
television show Illusionist but when it
comes to Ryan's facial hair I think
keeping things short and tidy but not
necessarily outlined again is a great
look for him I think there's something
about just being able to augment the
shape of his face and his jaw it gives
him a little bit more of a maturity and
I really like the look on him overall
especially when you contrast it against
no facial hair at all in which case he's
got a great jawline I mean there's
objectively nothing wrong with this
guy's face but it's almost too much it's
like there's just too much handsome
there leave some for the rest of us keep
the
beard Andre
3000 Andre 3000 is a style icon this guy
has absolutely taken his look to very
very solid extremes and a lot of the
time he likes to change his facial hair
inside of that now let's look at him
with a full beard here you can see that
it really fills out the bottom area of
his face and gives him an overall
rounder kind of shape but when you
transition to something more of a goatee
style you can see that it stretches the
face shape out and makes them look a
little longer and leaner now there's
varying degrees of how well sculpted
that beard style is you can see with the
mustache and anchor style it's very very
sculpted and looks a little bit much I
actually kind of prefer him in the first
shape which is just a little looser more
casual it has a I care less what you
think kind of vibe and I think that
always reads really well when it comes
to style so when it comes to andere 3000
I like him with a bit of a goti style
not necessarily a full
beard David
Beckham David Beckham is also a style
icon but I think he has a very different
style and it's really transitioned
throughout the years he's tried many
different haircuts in many different
looks but the one that I think he
settles on the most when it comes to his
facial hair is what we call shape
stubble and shape stubble really gives
you the outline or the shadow of a beard
without necessarily creating a lot of
texture or change to the face shape
grimming tip number 98 if you find
trimming your beard once a week to be
too high maintenance try shaving my
favorite look for David Beckham is when
he wears shaped stubble that is nice and
kept neat and short but not necessarily
outlined he already has very strong
growth areas so he doesn't necessarily
need to enhance that using sharper lines
you can see here in this style that he's
starting to grow his shape out a little
bit and it makes him look a little
frumpy and a little bit more chubby in
the cheek area and in this next shot
where he's just a little bit leaner
looking that's because it's kept nice
and tight and he hasn't allowed it to
grow out and create like a wider
silhouette for his face but now let's
look at David Beckham without a beard at
all I mean I know this is an older photo
but he kind of has a baby face and I
think that wearing that stubbled shape
really brings out more of a masculine
sex appeal so for me I'm I'm going to
have to say short stubble is his best
look Tom
Hardy Tom Hardy is a great
representation of somebody that uses his
beard to give him a more Rough and Ready
appeal it's never overg groomed it's
always just a little rough and I think
that's perfect for him I've seen
pictures of him and film roles where
he's gone clean shaven and while he is
objectively an incredibly handsome man
he always looks better with a beard to
me it just seems to suit his personality
better I mean Tom hard always looks like
he should perpetually have a bit of a
Mad Max Vibe or like he just climbed off
of a really scary looking motorcycle you
know so for me this type of shape on him
works really really well I mean here
he's got a little bit more of a grown
out beard and even though his beard
growth is not particularly dense it
grows in all the right places it gives
him a very strong looking chin which is
what's so great about this look for him
and even when he wears a shaped stubble
it's not really that shaped it's just
kind of grown in and there's something
about it that really works for him this
does not work for every guy a lot of
guys when they try and grow this kind of
shape in that doesn't necessarily have
any outline or any kind of cleanup to it
they just start to look kind of dirty
but something about that works for Tom
Hardy grooming tip number 900 when
triming your beard less is more start
small remove more as needed if you start
with too much you may be back to the
drawing board expressing your
personality through your beard is not
just about the shape that you choose
it's about the way that you groom it as
well now if if I had to pick between
clean shaven and bearded I'm 100%
bearded on this
one Dev
Patel now Dev is a perfect example of
what you should do if you have a patchy
growth this one is for my patchy Kings
out there okay just because you don't
grow a full thick beard doesn't mean you
can't have something that can be
complimentary to your face shape you can
see here in this image that he's
actually grown out a really nice even
dispensation of hair and it gives him
just a little bit of a rougher feel and
he's paired it really nice with a
hairstyle that works with that Vibe so
this is a really great way to grow a
little bit of a beard without
necessarily overdoing it when you have
hair like this that is a little bit
Patchy the longer you grow it the more
diminishing returns it can have so it's
actually probably a good idea to keep it
a little on the shorter side which is
really good because right now shorter
beards are starting to come back into
fashion and longer beards we're not
seeing as much now it's not that you
can't grow this style out it's just that
when you do it's going to start taking
on a very different shape now you can
see here that as he starts to grow the
beard out he's playing to the strengths
of his beard but the darker areas and
the heavy mustache and the shaping
starts to make look kind of like a
villain so my favorite look for Dev is
definitely going to be the shorter
closer little bit rough beard without
the strong
outlines
common I've always really loved Common's
style it's always been really
understated and very classic and cool
he's not somebody that chases a lot of
Trends and he's definitely somebody that
is a great understanding of his own
style but when it comes to his facial
hair you can see he's tested the waters
in a few different shapes but when it
comes to Common's face shape he's really
created a nice kind of square shape on
his beard I like him with a fuller beard
I think this looks really good and he
keeps it very wellmaintained which is
very complimentary to his face shape and
instead of letting everything turn very
very round as often happens with bald
guys he's got a really nice strong
anchor to the bottom of his face shape
which creates this strong jaw shape for
him keeping things a little more Square
another really great way to do that is
sometimes by wearing a goatee style
which he's also done having a goatee
style is a great way to elongate your
face shape especially if you don't have
hair on top it can give you just a
little more interest to your face and
create a slightly more square shape as
far as which one I prefer I think I'm
going to go full beard on this one now I
know I said short beards are in but
something about that look works for me
and I kind of Dig
It Jack
harlo now Jack harlo is somebody that I
don't think is particularly well known
for his beard I mean he's got those
really awesome curls and I think girls
find that really dreamy which is great
but when it comes to his beard it's not
super thick or super defined and that's
okay like don't let yourself be
discouraged just cuz you can't grow the
thickest beard on Earth but it does mean
that when you're wearing certain things
with it you are going to emphasize the
shape or thinness of the beard like
turtlenecks turtlenecks is not a good
style Choice when you have a really thin
patchy beard that you're trying to grow
out because it really shows how thin and
how patchy it is especially if you're
using solid colors like very black or
very white very black is going to show
almost entirely the outline of the beard
and it's going to make the hair appear
lighter a white background is actually
going to show how thin and see-through
the beard is so if you have this type of
beard make sure you're not pairing it up
with very solid bright colors that
you're wearing underneath it and try and
keep your neck area somewhat
exposed Jason
schwarzman Jason schwarzman is I think a
very transformative actor I love all of
the stuff that he does with his Wes
Anderson films especially because he
uses his facial hair to capture and
embody elements of his characters and
that's one thing that I think is really
interesting people that try different
facial hair really does Express
different things look at this picture of
Jason schwarzman with a full beard like
my God look at that thing he looks like
a high fashioned model like this is just
a very cool look and maybe it's the
longer hair maybe it's the suit but I
think the beard is doing a lot of heavy
lifting but what it really demonstrates
is what he's capable of growing now
let's look at a couple of the other
styles that he chooses through some of
his films like this one from asteroid
City this was a very bold choice he's
got very low lines it disconnects from
most of the rest of his face shape his
disconnected mustache he's got that
little soul patch in the middle it
definitely has a kind of an older timey
vibe to it and it's not what we see in
most modern beards but it also kind of
draws his face shape out and makes his
cheeks like a little droopy so sometimes
when you take those lines too low they
really start to expose a lot more of
your face than you wish it had and it
changes the overall shape Ian let's go
back to here where he just has a
mustache and again you can see what a
dramatic difference his face shape takes
on when you adjust the size and volume
of his facial hair I have seen him
without facial hair as well it makes him
look a little bit younger and overall I
think the most striking look here for
Jason is the full
beard John Cho now jono is an actor that
we're used to seeing clean shaving
without a beard at all but we came
across this picture of him with a goatee
and I'm here for it I honestly think
this looks a little bit more badass this
has got kind of a cooler look for his
face especially when contrasted against
to how he looks without a beard at all
now when it comes to the density of a
goatee or the shape of a goatee
sometimes you just have to work with
what you got he's just playing with the
areas of his face shape that are
probably the fullest and most dense
which creates a really nice shape around
his mouth a little bit of articulation
and a stronger point at the bottom of
his face this is a very flattering look
for John when it comes to a goatee there
are a few things you want to think about
when it comes to making it suitable to
your face shape first of all when you
don't have a strong growth that connects
your soul patch down to the main part or
the anchor part of the goatee you really
quickly get into a shape that we refer
to as a circle beard and a circle beard
can look okay but it's not always the
most flattering thing the way to keep it
flattering is to make sure that those
Sidelines are nice and straight keeping
those right angles nice and strong prev
prevent things from looking a little too
circular around the mouth in which case
it just kind of makes your face look
wider and a little chubbier honestly I
like JN Cho with a
goatee DJ
Ked now when it comes to beard shapes
that look like this you'll probably
notice something looks a little
different I mean it goes from zero to
100% density within the space of a few
millimeters and that's not actually
realistic and that's because beards like
this rely on something called
enhancements they're usually a paint or
a powder product that are used to make
the beard appear more dense and there's
a lot of artistry that goes into doing
this type of beard but there's not a lot
of permanence they're sprayon hair
fibers and they use different shapes to
try and enhance the look of a beard
which is really cool look that day so if
you are looking at a picture of this and
wishing you could have this beard you're
probably not going to have it with your
own natural growth this is the type of
thing that you're going to need to go to
a professional for and those
enhancements they really only last a
couple of days so if you're planning on
wearing this out for something you're
going to have to go get it redone like
that day and pray that it's not raining
but when it comes to whether or not this
beard shape works for DJ khed it most
certainly does the actual shape that has
been let's just call it painted on his
face is very flattering to his look it
works perfectly with his face shape and
also works with his style so it's not a
judgment call on whether or not it's
okay to wear enhanced beards it has
everything to do with whether or not
those enhancements are going to
complement or detract from the face
shape and in this case I think it works
pretty good Tom
Ford if I could put one phrase to
describe Tom Ford it would be
understated cool the thing about his
style and about his design work is that
it's always been very classic and
Timeless and very seldom is it overtly
flashy but it is always cool and I think
he takes that same approach with his his
facial hair I love the look of Tom Ford
with a beard and I don't want to see him
with a full beard I like him with just a
short clean stubble because it really
enhances the look of his face it gives
the maturity of his years that he has
earned but overall he looks great both
ways the one thing I will say is in this
particular picture this is a little bit
of a weird thing because normally when
you wear a beard style it Blends into
your haircut and here you can quite
clearly see where Tom's Sideburn has
kind of been left a little more solid
what that tells me is he very likely
didn't get that done in a barber shop or
a hair salon that was likely something
that he decided to grow in after he got
his haircut so that's a good tip for you
guys that want to grow in a beard make
sure that once it grows to an adequate
length you blend it into your Sideburn
to make it look a little more uniform
and cohesive with the rest of your
haircut I I mean there's not a lot of
bad things you can say about Tom Ford
when it comes to style in fact I feel
weird talking about Tom Ford's style
because he is style and I'm just a
barber in Canada with with a beard and a
cowboy
hat Jeffrey
Wright now when it comes to guys like
Jeffrey Wright this is an actor that's
made a fairly significant transition in
front of us we've seen him go from
having a little bit of hair and no beard
to having no hair and a lot of beard and
one of the things I really like about
his beard is its density he's got a
really nice dense growth on his face
shape and he keeps it in that salt and
pepper kind of shape but still nice and
tightly groomed the cool thing about
this is it really enhances the shape of
his jaw gives him a really strong
prominent jawline and makes him look I
think objectively very handsome so
Jeffrey Wright with a beard is an
absolutely fantastic look thanks a lot
for watching you guys maybe you agreed
with me on some of these assessments and
maybe not either way that's cool style
is all about wearing what you have
confidently and if you like it then it's
cool if you think we left somebody off
this list drop a comment below I mean
there is a whole wide world of beards
out there to explore and maybe we can
explore them together until then good
luck and good
grooming